you know what a podcast is good and when
you detest time flies Lyn's
that was fun we're not done yet almost
done we're almost double not quite done
yet I gotta go
yeah I know yeah I know you know you got
[ __ ] to do but just give me a second
okay at the end what we do is we call do
a thing called unhelpful advice okay and
it's an email from one of our fans our
listeners and we try to give them advice
and then we wrap it up okay but the
advice has to be it can be helpful or
just protects us what I say it's
unhelpful that's what we call it that
I'll help advice with Bobby
kalila at Lindsay Price Second City
right there I would like to get your
opinion I found amazing girl we can talk
for hours and I seem to connect with her
so easily she's also a big fan of Tiger
valium after a couple of days she
messaged me and said she just wants to
be friends
mainly because I live in Australia and
she is in the States
she said that she would totally go out
with me if I live closer but she wants
us to stop growing our feelings towards
each other I like her enough to know
that she was supposed she is a special
one and she is good for me and I want to
keep talking to her what should I do
max PK you're not gonna move for a girl
Australian he's in Australia it's Curtis
stones brother that's a long-distance
relationship with the guy from Australia
Australian bean yeah that was that's way
too long of a flight even for me it was
and it's expensive and I don't know how
that's just it wasn't sustainable for me
at all I mean we dated probably for a
year and I that was my max I was like
you know I can't do this
but they could like communicate right
via email and and you know talk on the
phone and it's based on Skype and
whatever else yeah and then if it's good
enough someone can move you can always
move like something like life isn't that
ponent I'm gonna say something that's
the most helpful thing I really believed
this and this is usually my advice is
she shouldn't take because it's
[ __ ] up but what I would do is I was
like okay you want to be friends okay
we'll be friends and just keep it at
that and have make a relationship based
on friendship and that she might change
you know meet her I would do long game
on it because there's nothing because
the only option after that is moving and
that's not a guarantee in fact I would
feel weirded out if a woman moved from a
different country just to see if she
wanted to date my back no that's needy
and weird and intrusive yards there's no
way so sure we cuz when I dated that guy
he stayed here for seven weeks and I
couldn't wait to get him out cuz we had
just started seeing each other and it
was still relatively new and he was like
I got a ticket to go there and I felt
depression I'm like wait you're gonna be
in my house yeah for seven weeks I got a
host you and I don't know you that well
we're still kind of seeing if we even
want to go there but then that
commitment because he's already flown 17
hours and I'm like [ __ ] pack his bags
and go yeah you're gonna [ __ ] it up by
being needy so I just be friends and
keep it at that and if you know if you
get something you know if it grows into
something else that's cool but a
friendship is cool too and there's
plenty of a girls in Austral you'll find
somebody damn it there's a lot of fish
how old is this kid did she say no age
what's his name PK PK yeah he's 12
he's you want to promote something or
not yeah
it's an ABC hit comedy can't say it
without stuttering it said what it was
that the inner email said it's been 10
years what a premiere they said that in
a lot of years nothing has ever has
rated as well and this timeslot
I think it's like four years oh four
years
Oh in ten years only three shows did
better that's what it was like the
premiere of scrubs yeah right yeah so I
might I might know you for five or six
years here or or I may never see you
again
I may never see you again you know but
[ __ ] Oliver Hudson because Tuesday night
I've been [ __ ] texting that
[ __ ] the great numbers and that
and he gave me like and went well and
that's it and I texted him a bunch of
times so let's have like a text
he's the worst at texting and we've had
him on the show and he admitted it and
I'm done with him this this week yeah
but you think and then wait a year and
then Jenna might do what yeah because I
I love her and we're very friendly and I
love her I really do but I think that
it's reverence I have a fear of her and
also I don't have the seems that I have
with her or like in a party or it's
never like so don't I wasn't able to
like hang out with her just her and I
and get to know her in that way
whereas Lindsey had and I had a lot of
like downtime where we sat around for
hours talking she's fancy like she's
fancier than you and me though she's
pretty [ __ ] fast yeah yeah so I yeah
what is he honest ricotta a kutari
platter like figs she's know she's like
a caviar oh she's a caviar like a
dry-aged some kind of you guys I'm the
pickle on the corner of the thing that
people don't even know to eat yeah what
is this garnish garnish yeah what are
you on I'm the I'm like the bread fresh
out of the oven
a lot and you can't do without me right
I'm not that like yeah fancy like
[Laughter]
honesty Linds yeah that was great
and you should do more podcasts really
yeah I feel like I didn't do that well
she should be a tiger Billie exclusive
no other podcast but our yeah yeah any
other is there like a podcast circuit
yes there is it really is very much
bigger than ours bigger than ours
yeah yeah I mean we're don't work we're
not this is not the bottom now this is
upper mid yeah this is upper men on a
charcuterie local summit salami yeah
we're okay prosciutto shut up man
okay you [ __ ] we're like an empirical
not a serrano a jamon iberico oh just a
touch higher hired Ron Oh applause or
Lindsey
[Applause]
[Music]